previously on model lifestyle finally we
arrived at the leaders door and we
started the photo shoot I was wondering
if it really is a good idea to stay here
in Cape Town longer because now that
I've seen the water crisis and all the
models fighting to survive the low
amount of castings and clients I can't
control any of it but I do have a wife
to take care of and and Belle's need to
be paid
[Music]
[Applause]
but I think I know what to do
[Music]
hi if this is your first time on my
channel subscribe and hit the bell so
you won't miss the next video
[Music]
I know what to do I'm going to ask my
mother agency get me a contract in
another country as soon as possible but
it will take them a few days so I can
either sit here and complain about my
bad situation or I can get up and enjoy
my last few days here in Cape Town after
all the happiest people don't have the
best of everything they just make the
best of everything so the next day I
went to hike up the famous Table
Mountain with a few friends
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
one label Mamta
[Music]
the reason sit down try to keep me down
I'll put the flame out you can't get to
me so we made it we're on tables come on
guys
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
shoot me down
[Music]
[Applause]
anyway
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
push me down to the ground goes around
comes around you won't put the flame out
what you can't get to me say what you
want to say go take it I decided to go
and make another video for my youtube
channel with Gavin from my agency in
Cape Town we talked about what do model
agencies look for in regards to new
models and this is how it looked like
I'm here my boss I'm working with Gavin
here in Decatur and I asked him if he
can explain to you guys how do you know
I can be a model
alright so Kevin okay so it's finding a
model this is quite a tricky thing
because we get to see a lot of people on
a daily basis everybody messages are
saying I want to be a model so there's a
couple of things to keep in mind
particularly for a male model and these
are kind of international requirements
you need to be of a certain height now
it's not exactly kind of like science if
you have some free time after this video
go and check it out
I also went on a really fun bike ride
with the cell group of Life Church
[Music]
[Music]
every possibility is it dangerous
they don't have any brakes
[Music]
ooh be careful downhill with no brakes
[Music]
dangerous people - cool yeah see
Sall group is crossing the red light we
are such an example
[Music]
Casey
[Music]
their life without boring people my god
whoa Jesus will love your everything and
wonderful people
[Music]
I started to spend more time with this
cell group because I experienced
unconditional love between them and
these were people from different races
within a country where racism is still
high and yet love brought them together
like a real family this is something
that the world can learn from
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
Hey
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
time went on and I made more YouTube
videos so what is the best sunglasses
for men in 2018 well there's a lot of
sunglasses out there a lot of shapes a
lot of sizes a lot of brands right but
the most important thing when it comes
to sunglasses is the shape of the lasas
why is that so important well it's real
I'm gonna talk about the best fashion
accessories for men in 2018 the best
fashion accessories are those that will
never go out of style so let's start
with the first one the wallet the next
day we went to hike up a lions head to
look at a most beautiful sunrise that I
have ever seen
[Music]
[Music]
I can't
good morning guys so we made it on lions
head and we're not alone there's a lot
of people here to come and check out the
sunrise thanks Neela there is check out
this sunrise
[Music]
me
[Music]
the sound is me
[Music]
a changeling
when
[Music]
finally I heard back from my mother
agency with a few options but it would
take a few days to apply for a visa
once I chose the country that I want to
go to so I decided to go back home to
Nikita and apply for a visa there as I
was leaving I looked at my room for the
last time and I thought to myself even
if the modeling did not work out I still
made some great memories here my own
apartment for the next two months
[Music]
stones which ISA leading us love is all
wheel ever trust no I don't always
[Music]
through wastelands through the highways
so my shadow through sunrays and
[Music]
I will definitely miss Cape Town but I
miss my wife a lot more and I cannot
wait to see her
[Music]
the sunshine where that plane
finally I was back home with Nikita and
we could not leave each other alone for
10 minutes even in doing normal stuff
like to go buy groceries because we knew
the time would come when I would leave
again
[Music]
and then the day came when my agency and
I chose my next modeling contract my
babes
I know Korea wants you badly I can
confirm you with them ASAP a few days
flew by and now I'm on the internet to
check-in from my next flight to South
Korea the next day we were on our way to
the how train that will take me to the
airport
[Music]
[Music]
this is my plan right here check it out
[Music]
[Music]
hi if this is your first time on my
channel subscribe and hit the bell so
you won't miss the next video
[Music]